um okay I am so sorry for her behavior
born you should be you gotta tell me
when you seriously like get control of
your woman this is unacceptable
hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Lauren
gone we're gonna watch the trailer day
for a little movie starring a really
respected actress who starred in the
Twilight movies yay called camp x-ray
people are jacked up about this for some
because acting is really really good I
you know honestly Lauren goth I really
don't know but I'm willing to find out
let's find out I haven't read anything
about this movie so let's do it yeah
that's why it's a great show because
it's a trailer reaction I know Ryan I'll
be reacting to it yeah it's gonna be raw
and authentic brief nude images can't
get excited about that make no mistake
about it this is a war zone
yeah Brad some of these guys have been
locked up in here for eight years you
will refer to them as detainees you will
not call them prisoners you can talk to
him but do not let these guys know
anything about you do not let them get
inside your head
I pleaded sentence I mean it has Kristen
Stewart how did you end up in this place
how did you end up it's been a very long
time that I have been waiting not
knowing how all these things are going
to end all you things can change
hey did you like it here in Guantanamo
Bay no no it's not as black and white as
they said it was gonna be
I never agree to follow your nose if I
follow your rules
it means that I'm agreeing that you have
the right to give the rules but you
don't one of your guys here you told me
that he doesn't even but I still cannot
no country no city do you take me
because I've been here you and me we are
at war
what is the most depressing movies
playing some deaths
my cousin everyone that come back comedy
called don't we not gonna get up no one
here goes into it
all joking aside it does look like a
pretty good movie though seriously
though it looks like a really great
movie but I would take it so much more
seriously if it had a different starring
actress it is a little bit hard to get
my mind wrapped around it like normally
I'm like I can accept this but I
honestly I'm having a difficult time
Kristen Stewart has worked a lot the
first thing I ever saw her in was panic
room yes which I remember liking that
was such a long time ago I loved it but
then it's like well how did she why was
she's such a bad actress in Twilight why
did that happen
she probably just didn't care it's like
when James but they were paying her
enough money to care yeah but you know
there's a lot of people when they get
paid a lot just don't care
fully I do see the waters of the
Caribbean ik thing
what no I have it yeah well Johnny Depp
certainly stopped giving a [ __ ] I'm not
a really big Johnny Depp fan you guys
hate me whatever you just sometimes see
the worst things first you say you
didn't like dawn of the Planet of the
Apes and now you're saying this dude
also why did they put him in into the
woods he can't sing yeah you can't party
know you didn't like Sweeney Todd yeah
you know this isn't about Johnny Depp
okay it's enough Kristen Stewart how she
sucks I know she's done some good work
actually now maybe like that that one
reduces that she was transfixing so mate
hopefully that's true because I feel
like this could be a really powerful
movie and it tells a really great story
if every single actor on that movie
isn't doing a phenomenal job then it's
not going to have the impact that it
could yeah I mean but Lauren let's keep
in mind this is just a trailer okay yeah
so she might be as amazing as some
people are making out to be I hope but
as far as even the story goes I think
the story itself is like really know
that she toes in my heart and I start to
cry a lot so the guy I'm a big fryer
it's cracked already came with her you
uh be like what are you crying about I'm
not gonna tell you that's what keeps
doing mysterious thank you guys for
letting me know that trailer was out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe that's awesome
and Lauren has a channel
you can subscribe yeah it's like love
wine I don't know how that happened but
I mean apparently people like when we
talk about relationship issues people
just like to hear your opinion okay well
I have plenty of them so that's very
true hey Lauren
I wish Brian I'm gonna shout some people
out shout out
Darin Mortimer Ryan can I get a shoutout
please because I have a big dick this
guy no was how to connect I mean if you
really wanted a shout-out you shoulda
said that he has a big day that actually
would have worked laddering that would
have worked better yeah now that I
really think about it why don't you I
mean come on Darren it's possible to get
a picture of my dick Oh God
I'm not gonna tell you how but I'll tell
you that I have shared it online before
it's true actually
is it Jeff this is true sir sure things
know he shares dick pics he's sent dick
texts people this I can vouch for a lot
of people do that
no they don't yeah they do you just
don't run in those circles you're like
my conservative Christian oh you wait a
minute so um we're not gonna talk about
this anymore
no Jeremy Rodriguez hope he goes great
with Veronica Congrats
Jeremy rhodium I'm more excited about
the shout out part of it yeah just like
someone shadow um shout out jeez man
come on and I like your name like Jeremy
shine my best friend who wants this
piece of eye candy yeah he hasn't told
me this but we all know we all know
watch the pokemon red vs. blue honest
game trailer reaction and if you don't
want to watch the whole thing just watch
the last four minutes you'll know I know
for it's shorter than you can watch the
last like two minutes yeah it's worth
every second really silly anyway Jeremy
yeah that's what I wanted Italy Mayson
boss eight seven eight that's my boy
he's referring to the fact that I got
with Veronica Oh
can you give me a shout-out please it
would mean a lot please is all in caps
and it has
a link what does that mean let's find
out interesting what's happening search
results takes you to info man but what
has happened
I don't know word please takes you to
info man baby bananas
maybe Mason boss eight seven eight is
trying to sell us something maybe you
just got a virus on your computer I get
a lot of those because of all the porn
sites that you're on hey whoa I stopped
looking at porn a few weeks ago so it's
okay he's only saying that because
Veronica's in the next room
what I I don't even remember her I'm I
remember her being there I just don't I
wasn't oh [ __ ]
digging yourself into a bigger hole
right now yeah anyway Mason boss eight
seven eight um yeah there you go
you were acknowledged